lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
analizar las diferencias entre la
demanda y la cantidad demandada aquí
tenemos una gráfica de precio y cantidad
para una marca x de autos en el mercado
aquí vemos la curva de demanda para
dicha marca de autos y vemos que sigue
el comportamiento clásico de la ley de
la demanda cuando el precio es mayor hay
poca cantidad demandada aquí vamos a
comenzar a ver la diferencia la cantidad
demandada q de uno está asociada a un
punto en particular de la gráfica de
demanda y no con toda la curva cuando
las personas hablan de la demanda se
refieren a toda la curva pero
continuando con lo que mencioné y
siguiendo con la ley de la demanda
cuando hay un precio menor esto se
asocia con una mayor cantidad demandada
q de 2 así pues la cantidad demandada es
un punto particular en la curva de
demanda mientras que la curva de demanda
es el conjunto de todos los puntos que
muestran cómo se asocian la cantidad y
el precio a lo largo de toda la curva
con esto en mente y para comprenderlo
con un ejemplo tangible
veamos varias circunstancias y
analicemos cierre
en un cambio en la demanda o en un
cambio en la cantidad demandada el
primer escenario dice los vendedores de
autos rebajan los precios 10% esto
resulta en un cambio en la demanda es
decir en un desplazamiento en la curva
de demanda o involucra un desplazamiento
dentro de la misma curva es decir un
cambio en la cantidad demandada pausa en
el vídeo y piensen en ello hay un par de
formas en las que podemos averiguar esto
revisemos si se trata de un
desplazamiento de toda la curva o de un
movimiento dentro de la misma curva lo
primero lo que tenemos que pensar es en
determinar un precio o tener un precio
inicial no está descrito aquí pero no
resulta en un cambio de la cantidad
demandada al menos no directamente a
este precio y no tampoco nos dice que a
este precio determinado cambie la
actitud de los consumidores para que
toda la curva de demanda sea desplazada
esto solamente desplaza el precio por lo
que es un desplazamiento sobre la misma
curva este es un escenario que
llamaremos la cantidad demandada 3 en el
que el precio de equilibrio del cual
hablaremos con más detalle en futuros
vídeos
y la cantidad demandada que estaban
asociadas con este punto antes de que
los vendedores de autos re bajarán los
precios es el momento en el que los
precios bajan terminando en este punto
de la curva de demanda así que esto es
lo que hace que cambie la cantidad
demandada 4 esto es un cambio en la
cantidad demandada usamos delta para
indicar cambio y en este caso la
cantidad demandada aumenta que pasa
cuando aumenta el precio de la gasolina
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en qué es lo
que ocurrirá en este escenario cambiará
la cantidad demandada o la demanda
hagamos lo mismo elijamos un precio en
particular y digamos que esta es la
cantidad actual demandada si de pronto
para cualquier precio que elijamos
aumenta el precio de la gasolina los
consumidores tendrán menos dinero en su
bolsillo por el aumento en el costo de
usar y mantener un auto por lo que los
consumidores no querrán comprar tantos
autos esto es verdadero para cualquier
precio por lo que implica un cambio en
toda la curva de demanda esta es de 1 y
ahora tenemos de 2
así que tenemos un cambio en la demanda
y en este caso el cambio es hacia abajo
también se puede ver como un cambio
hacia la izquierda escribiremos que es
un cambio hacia la izquierda veamos el
tercer escenario disminuye el precio del
transporte público esto es un cambio en
la curva de demanda o en la cantidad
demandada uno de los sustitutos de los
autos es el transporte público y ahora
luce más atractivo para los consumidores
por lo que para cierto precio el mercado
no demandará a esa cantidad de nuevo
tenemos un cambio en la curva de demanda
esto es cierto para cualquier precio en
la curva de demanda por lo que la curva
se desplaza es un cambio en la demanda y
el cambio es hacia la izquierda es un
caso idéntico al punto anterior aquí
dice disminuyen las cuotas de registro
vehicular pausa en el vídeo y piensen en
esto sin importar dónde nos encontremos
en la curva de demanda si disminuyen las
cuotas de registro disminuye el costo
total de adquirir un auto por lo que
para cualquier precio las personas
pueden demandar una mayor cantidad de
autos
esto implica un aumento en la curva de
demanda hacia la derecha y le llamamos
de tres es un cambio en toda la curva de
demanda y no en una sola cantidad
demandada y el desplazamiento es hacia
la derecha porque deriva en un aumento
el quinto enunciado dice una recesión
disminuye los ingresos de las familias
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en ello este
enunciado es similar al del aumento en
el precio de la gasolina porque las
personas tendrán menos dinero para
comprar autos sin importar en qué punto
de la curva nos encontremos esto va a
desplazar toda la curva de demanda hacia
la izquierda el último escenario dice
los consumidores esperan un aumento en
el precio de los autos nuevos el próximo
año esto es un cambio en la curva de
demanda o en la cantidad demandada pausa
en el vídeo y piensen en ello esto es
algo que ocurre en cualquier punto de la
curva de demanda sin importar dónde esté
el precio de equilibrio del cual
hablaremos con más detalle en otros
vídeos si las personas esperan que
aumenten los precios el siguiente año
pueden imaginarse que la gente querrá
comprar
autos ahora por lo que toda la curva de
demanda se desplaza hacia la derecha
aquí lo importante es recordar que si
hablamos del cambio en un precio en
particular hablamos de un precio que
está determinado alguien o algo aumenta
o disminuye ese precio va a cambiar la
cantidad demandada más adelante al
dibujar la curva de oferta para ver en
donde intel seca con la curva de demanda
ubicamos el precio de equilibrio y
cuando una o ambas curvas cambien
también cambiará el punto de equilibrio
lo que resultará en un cambio en la
cantidad demandada pero si hablamos de
cosas que en general afectan la curva de
demanda sin importar en donde nos
encontremos en ella y afectará a las
personas que demandan entonces tendremos
un desplazamiento de toda la curva será
un cambio en la demanda en comparación
con un cambio en la cantidad demandada
que sólo será afectada por cambios en
los precios
nos vemos en otro vídeo